rock mas numero 8 non so se lo sentite è
una cosa non gli permette di fare mai ma
avevo freddo stanotte sviluppi chiuso
dai si inizia questa giornata
vengo da ricacciare carbotta il bando
non votando sì ma chi è carlotta longano
appare un regalato questo coso solamente
ieri è andato lei tu bumble cielo tipico
della cucina invece grazie cara politico
non azzardato ma regionale buonissimo e
buono è un fatto potrebbe della mezz'ora
se sei qua liste masticando è un dolce
multi uso la regolazione o il quadro al
muro del vicino si schiantò a spillo i
tassi sui sui laghi fonderia nata viva
mellberg solito passeggiatina allora sto
per dire un qualcosa di estremamente
impopolare alti quanti si stanno
lamentando del tempo in questi giorni
c'è a roma vedo coperto con un pochino
di pioggia lo trovo pazzesco
per me questo qui è il tempo ideale
della vita ecco perché ultimamente sto
sperimentando questa nuova tecnica che è
dormire tumulato dai miei animali e
quindi ieri notte mi sono ritrovato con
vulgo sotto le coperte stretto né dei
due gattino abbondanti infilare l'inter
con ci passo cosa deve succedere
quello si sta infilando in questo
passaggio non so come sei riuscito a
seguirlo quindi se lo stato con buglio
sotto le coperte appiccicato al menti
pompe russe e poi avevo tra il cussino
il collo così e nega paradiso la caccia
bisogno dell'amore quando sa tre animali
domestici
vai culpa e mostra via cavour che si fa
una passeggiata spinosa
macché famose ne andavo
smetti di essere così tranquillo
quasimodo quasimodo patimo quasimodo
quasimodo andiamocene dono troppo brezza
da gesù stressata ma ne vai anna ti
sento perché esista qualche mio piccione
non stomaco più dormendo sono una
persona tanto ho un dubbio esistenziale
perché riporta due a spasso e non sono
io a portarlo a spasso perché quando lui
conosce un territorio pur andato che
cazzo che farà lui e non riusciamo a
trovare una forma di compromesso acqua
come in una relazione o forse abbiamo
trovato marito una chance
l'inter torna il foehn altezza iso
ragazzi io comunque una domanda sono
queste mascherine che fanno sembrare a
tutti i più belli poi quando tipo le
togli pagano kay
forse è un problema mio le mascherine
fanno sembrare ogni simbolo essere
vivente cioè potenziale il materiale da
matrimonio anche dalle palle
può crescere qualcosa madonna che
pubblicità progresso per delle palle più
rigogliose questo se noi adesso lo
piantiamo dovrebbe uscire una lampadina
dovrebbe uscire una pianta di camomilla
ma quindi non si può mangiare fermo che
il problema sia mio mondo era una
schiena perché sono un inguaribile
ottimista quando stava davanti a una
sorpresina l'ovetto kinder pensava
sempre sarebbe stata quella che stava
cercando in realtà non lo era mai
potenziale materiale da navata e da
marcia nuziale è penosamente avere delle
turbe mentali che se lo portano dietro e
se lo divorano da almeno una vita che lo
rendono interessante la terra fatta
pongo non so quindi se anche voi avete
un curriculum vitae di disastri che
possono in qualche modo offendere mio
interesse
state lontani dai [ __ ] perché sto
riprendendo una cosa che non mi
interessa
graziano propri casi umani che mi
piacciono proprio quelli che se la
vivono male la vita sarà che forse una
parte di me vuole sentirsi migliore di
loro ma alla fine la mia parte peggiore
che esce quando sto insieme a loro ehi
ciao belli quindi dicevamo scarpanto
stercorario si è una palla fatta di
terra di pongo 3 like errico mangerà la
palla di kakà di stercorario allora a
50.000 like è ricoverato eccomi a palla
comunque vi chiedo perdono perché non so
perché mi sto rompendo i [ __ ] su
questa mia riflessione anche fatto in
maniera abbastanza spicciola
approssimativa altri casi umani
sull'amore e su questa roba qui la
verità è solo una rimarrà sempre quella
che quando hai cane e due gatti non è
proprio bisogno di nessuno il nostro
permette sopra i contatti un attimo che
a me sembra terra e terra e duratura è
già iniziata subito spappolare là dove
sei veramente maldestro e legno il legno
comunque ragazzi ieri ha cucinato
valentina oggi chef mario andrà in
cucina merda di un cane andiamo a
buttare la tua kakà che me la sto
trasportando manco fosse l'anello di
frodo ad ogni modo non mi copiano
passeggiata così da un bel po insieme al
mio cane aspetti
o altro materiale da matrimonio ai delle
tournée scusa ai delle turbe mentali e
un presente di non accettazione
ok no non vai bene allora come al solito
non c'è un cazzo qua dentro solo cibo
per animali
allora ragazzi oggi vi voglio bene io
vado a fare spesa è una sorpresa sul
piatto di fermarlo oggi vediamo da poco
non sono serio e sta facendo il cretino
prima che uno pensi che sto cercando di
lanciare delle frecciatine a qualcuno no
mi andava di fare un pochino lo scemo
accordo torniamo a casa del cristallino
fissando addosso tutti i balconi de roma
oppure un po rotto le palle fare video
con la gente mi guarda strano siamo a
monti curdo se vogliamo arriva a firenze
dove vogliamo andare dietro front
guardate guardate non vuole venire vieni
qui vieni quel mondo i loro denti se gli
fa certo se gli parlò così viene di ogni
cultura di cui bordo vieni qui vieni qui
funziona lo suggerisco a tutti quanti
voi parlate con la voce del demonio se
gli voglio bene un paio di pall
avevo bisogno di prendermi una boccata
d'aria o quasi quasi nevada cerca non
spacciatore dei veleni così in mezzo al
piatto che io faccio 6 giocavamo tutti
ok spesa fatta mi manca solo il veleno
bono guarda colmo della gara così ti
sembra di essere un po più
o tu l'hai con me mentre paganti
allenamento da qua c'è una cosa
eccezionale perché se tu te lo mangi da
solo di troppo con la modella troppo
troppo insieme per stampanti mar la
giorni e giorni e giorni gianmarco mario
ci fa vedere come si muoveranno fornelli
fatti vedere se comunque non riesco a
parlare in puglia lo stesso nome diverso
per beppe tu quando niente a un tale
fatto mentre cercava la band ammette mi
facevi secondo di carne stranieri con
rucola e pomodorini sfumata di vino
rosso e chiaramente fan e non le vostre
gallette implichi io col balsamico l'sp1
aceto di vino sembra veramente la
formula forte giocare meglio con i
lombardi uno stop che cosa o tono delle
orecchie cosa stai mangiando mettono
perso il suo di valdieri cielo
volutamente evitato
ho sentito dire non me ne frega un
quest'oggi faccio lo schifo cara insieme
persone evitando la miccia pulita piano
nella storia ottenere con noemi sono
state
sto aspettando che la mia assistente non
finisca di tagliare i pomodori
a quel punto metteremo la carne cala il
tris toccato forse no ai pomodori a
parte aggiungere i pomodori aggiungere
il vino per mantecare e spengo la calma
dopo aver messo il sale rucola cinque
minuti di riposo e siamo pronti come
paletta ok lobby della casa ma mi stavo
facendo vedere abbastanza quasi era in
bagno quando le 6 mm lì quasi facevo il
tuo gatto evans e giro ha già in bocca
una pallina risultato e quando gli dai
una pallina di carta che nel nostro
passatempo preferito come vedete questa
fa quando semplice mi ha capito c'è tv
indiana ma anche voi avete gatti che
ringhia non era prima con le mani il
tocco delle mani
se ti imponi re medico sistemi si
accende guarda
attiva è cagato sotto
pazzini attaccante che la zia allora
come andiamo chef
allora io avrei fatto sul piatto
classico della cucina italiana ha una
bella faccia è stata una scelta solo qua
viene mai io lo posso reason uno chef
riesco a fare tutto da solo
valentina era così giusto perso
allacciarmi guardate ti dico se è buono
fatto nel pop lavori sul ruolino mi
vorresti sentire buddha il sud cioè
parla ea manicini devi andare di là ed
irap al e di rispondere a gianmarco si
scena valentina da oggi risponderai a
sommare abbiamo qualche crepa dai
equilibria mo un po qui devo fare una
recitazione ma quando questi gatti è
molto importante il pane ed io lo
definisco pane assorbente agli
interventi che preferisci rispetto ad
altri che assolvono di più in questo è
parlato per gli straccetti guarda come
assorbe anche il sorgente risale poi
assorbito dal mare assorbente educare a
mano scusa ma
si fa questo
ma questo sale a una banca
la kabanga prefinito è andato sold out
pure del nostro link potete trovarlo su
amazon è che le scarpe della lidl è
andato fuori il mercato oppure lo trovi
a prezzi assurdi questo che ci paghiamo
l'affitto due bocce dh banda non basta
dormire ed ibra vada lo stima che manca
quanto a mero si ferma deve
riequilibrare i tuoi sensi non sono la
persona più indicata ma nostra pensioni
alcuni professionisti che potrebbe
riequilibrare i due sensi all'argomento
che sembrerebbero faccia sola dati che
tu non mi guardo io così da quest'altro
mettendo delle copertine agli animali
domestici 6 punti di allen ragazzi
allora si comanda non s'è cd subito su
da questo vecchio e sacro è visto che
periodo un attimo un po stressante che
in fatto di riequilibrare i vostri sensi
attraverso il riposo del guerriero just
wanna promettente ma notiamo interessato
solo interessato non ci volete libero ai
nostri sensi
io non sono una persona più indicata sì
però una situazione che fa al caso
vostro andata non ridete perché questa è
una cosa molto seria che cazzo stai
facendo
voglio anche mettete le mani fuori basse
metti le mani fuori falsi palmi rivolti
verso il basso trovate una posizione
critica
punito questo movimento adesso basta
parlare chiudete gli occhi voglio che
andate nel vostro mondo
provate un mondo ideale un mondo adatto
soltanto a voi dove non c'è giudizio
malignità udine un mondo spesso strato
in fondo all'inferno in cui sta
accadendo adesso valentino andate nel
vostro mondo non paese fornetti di
subito io bambino porta subito la
concentrazione dei piedi e rilassati e
rilassatevi
sentite questa concentrazione nel ieri
ma senza rispondere è il tuo mondo la
senti e adesso voglio che questa energia
la passate dai piedi la fate salire
lungo i polpacci verso le vostre
ginocchia
questa è una tecnica che si usa anche
per dormire infatti su cui adesso voglio
che non parli 10 punti melandri con
cazzo fresco e quindi continuerò a
parlare ma tu non sei serpeverde
stavolta l'energia adesso alle gambe al
dunque posta questa energia dargli un
calore dagli un colore mela faresti un
po più blu
piano piano la fate passare per le
braccia per le mani per la gola e
manipolati dall'interno del vostro corpo
il potere della mente e del popolo
hazard oyaya sentite se l'energia
a questo punto aprite gli occhi ognuno
col suo tempo che riprenda connessione
con il proprio oppo umano e non ha detto
alza piano togliere al misto come vedete
qui c'è un esempio di scarsa capacità
meditativa piano piano iniziate a
muovermi piano piano quando volete mi
siedo metri piedi ma lo ha funzionato
guglielmo ha funzionato solo
rilassatissimo bellissimo è stato utile
ragazzo intanto il mio come non lo ha
rigenerato sotto gli occhi meriti che
chiude blog
[Risate]